[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
so good we gotta get we gotta hear it
again Gary
all right Nevaeh thank you
hey Gary a lot going on this month a lot
going on this month we're just gonna
Dive Right In today we're talking about
social platforms and culture
um a lot to go through and super fired
up to bring John Morgenstern up our John
Morgenstern he's heads up all things
media buying and he helps keep us in
tune with what's now and what's next and
you guys are going to lay it down first
before we bring in some of the some of
our guests from the outside world jamo
yo yo it is here he is
Hey Jake good to see you brother how are
things
good a lot going on
indeed so chairman when we talk about
pack platforms and cultures it's a
acronym that we're spending a lot of
time here at Maine or for everybody
who's watching first of all let's give
some shout outs Sean tool I see you on
Facebook Jason Campbell on Facebook good
to see you Suzette on LinkedIn uh
Christian from Copenhagen on LinkedIn
Kevin H uh from Florida on YouTube thank
you for everybody who's tuning in we
have a big time show today
um I believe for everybody who's
watching entrepreneurs creators
influencers Fortune 5000 CEO CMOS
Fortune 500 CEOs CMOS B2B b2c I believe
that being an expert in the platforms
and in what's happening in culture is
the only way to be a contemporary
marketer when you when you hear being
consumer-centric when you think about
your career coming from social code
being in marketing for a long time
spending a ton of times with the
platforms on the media side
what what stands out in this in this
framework what have you learned here at
Vayner in the last 10 years on this that
you know was something maybe you didn't
believe as much like give everyone a
little layland of your brilliant mind
yeah um
we've talked about this before Gary it
feels like in many ways like right now
is is the 2011 2012 Vibes platforms wise
as far as like it's chaotic some things
feel early like hacks organic is back um
and those were like the Glory Days those
are really fun times for me right
because running ads in Facebook in 2011
there was no news feed ads it was
desktop only two ad units like just
figuring it out on the Fly
I think
consumer-centric platform-centric to me
as it pertains to the the media buying
side is like being super close to all
the features that the platforms are
rolling out like Tick Tock right now
with saves like favorites you know the
bookmark icon
that we think is such a good signal
we're like okay people are going to come
back to this later you can see it in ads
reporting you can see it like catch on
as you run ads so people are using this
more and it's like an interesting signal
when you can't track towards purchase so
like following all the different
features and things going on with the
platforms then seeing it roll into like
adsland
um and like playing around with the ads
interface
as you know educate a lot of people here
who don't work in five Fortune 500 land
something as small as a save function in
Tick Tock as a feature from the platform
the p
that's not something a CMO a Fortune 500
company even gives a sh doesn't even
know is happening let alone gives a [ __ ]
about correct yes
100 most media buyers don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I mean fortune 5000 company just
don't give a [ __ ] this is kind of the
point that we're trying to make in this
session right that these little nuances
of the understanding of the platforms is
actually big dividends for building
brand and businesses yes yes
and that we see entrepreneurs a lot of
time or very small companies take
advantage of this and this is why we've
seen so much market share gains in the
last decade because this is the fashion
Nova's this is the you know uh all birds
this is the Warby Parkers this is the
Harry's this is all these cpj uh Mr
Beast Burgers Fernando's coming up in a
little bit like these are the things
that we're seeing literally a human
being the garyvee's the Mr Beast the
demilio like like if you are perfect at
platform you can out flank the biggest
companies in the world because they're
all the way at reaching frequency and
they don't give a [ __ ] about this little
Nuance we're arguing here these little
nuances times 75 across 12 platforms and
then we'll get to the culture part is
the punch line of opportunity yes
yes yeah and and like how big agencies
typically get the flow of information
like hey new new literature new hotness
new best practices from the platforms
the Delta has never been farther apart
we're like I'm in a bunch of Facebook
groups of like me media buying ninjas
and like Facebook ads entrepreneurs and
like the insights and the things they're
messing with and like doing and noting
it's like a different universe and it
used to be closer it used to be like
yeah like lookalikes are good
um and it's just so different now it
keeps me on my toes because everyone
because of you and it's like oh you're
Gary's media buying person like they're
throwing all their heat at me
um and so I just I just like stay on my
toes like it's it's so democratized that
it's all about like
as a math kid
the culture which is really the art what
have you learned about for example the
green screen that I did for winetext.com
right like what are you learning around
the culture part that maybe is
defragging that brilliant bath brain of
your last decade
yeah I mean it's
when we talk about it some people are
entrepreneurs like Facebook ad you know
junkies are like yeah I've been doing
that but it really as intuitive as it is
it hasn't been where
outside of reach and frequency where you
always make out the point of like hey
that's potential Impressions like you
know just because they watched a second
or two that might mean that's just the
average time it takes to scroll through
a news feed
um
the the rub was well what could supplant
those metrics for like do you have
people's attention and the rise of the
tick tock error it was like does it get
organic distribution because if if Tick
Tock if reels if Shorts like takes your
content and shows out organically like
they don't [ __ ] around in those
algorithms with like potential reads
it's like is this good for our users so
that signal of like you have the
attention and reading the requests and
comments like I just watched this I'm
gonna buy it like what you've always
said
um that matters a lot and then using
that as the seed of what goes into your
ads like the ads paid world is just a
subset of the organic world it's the
same stuff
um but you have to fuse it with business
and it can't just be like you know teddy
bears and random viral stuff you have to
be thoughtful that's why we call it
strategic organic content but to to just
give a ton of value for the
entrepreneurs and Executives give me on
the platform side the jmo top 10 and
whether it's 10 or 7 can give me 10
little nuances of products on the
organic or medium side that you're
obsessed or curious or excited about
right now you know snap spot like this
or Pinterest that or be real this or
Twitter that give me a [ __ ] November
16 2022 jamo special I'll throw I'll
throw all my heat um and some I actually
just got from you so big UPS
um the green screen hack is like number
one because it's so easy
um where you can just like screenshot an
article do a green screen over it or if
it's not you hire a Creator influencer
someone who works at the brand to do it
um you can do many a day all sorts of
Articles uh Gallery will write articles
just to be green screened
um it's ridiculous easy and works like
that's where your content on on blind
text where you did a green screen
did way better than all the stuff you
actually like spent more way more time
shooting and doing so that's number one
across platforms
um tick-tocking reels on
reels this might be something you
haven't heard
um
Instagram reels but it's probably the
same on both I can only say for sure
with Instagram reels the the audio you
choose like matters more than on Tick
Tock like if you use the top like
funny sound that's trending on reels you
can draft off of that trend
more than you can on Tick Tock like
notably more yeah
that's one
that gives to the whole rub about music
and like licensing and rights and I do
have a lot of empathy for brands with
that I know you
you do too that's always tricky
um
but those two are really interesting my
third is an ads hack which is around how
to like force serve your your YouTube
ads just in shorts because Google
doesn't want you to do that and they
make it tricky
um so we're using that with a lot of
Brands right now because you're talking
a video game about shorts organic
they're of course coming to me and are
like let's do ads but YouTube video
action it's like we'll just serve it
everywhere don't worry about it so to do
the shorts hack we had to like Tinker it
was again old school like 2011 2012
stuff
um that's number three we're out of time
jamo we got to keep it moving I love you
thank you we'll have you back for sure
later
we gotta get we gotta get him back for
the other five
I believe he's got big he's got so much
all right we're lucky to have Fernando
Machado come back he uh joined us when
he was all about burgers and now he's
all about gaming Fernando you can tell
he's he leads some of the marketing for
the most exciting titles including Call
of Duty World of Warcraft OverWatch
Candy Crush and so much more we're super
fired up to have you back Fernando now
it's my pleasure to be here oh it's fun
to to be with you guys again
Fernando have you been my friend I'm
good man I was looking for like someone
who had a more clutter shelf than mine
at home and I finally yeah I have a
similar collection though
we got to talk about that offline um
everybody's watching Fernando is you
know I'm gonna make him blush here truly
actually a legend in the marketing
industry one of the most admired sought
after
um respected CMOS in the world uh
obviously now uh running the helmet
Activision Blizzard no no when you when
you see the you know platforms and
culture what does it really mean to be
consumer-centric the Burger King work
now here in in this entertainment media
gaming World you've really had the
fortune and and probably this is why you
selected them to be at the helm of
brands that people really care about and
that are really consumer-centric truly
actually
um so you know when you see this what
does it really mean to be
consumer-centric how do you answer that
from your purview
look I mean I try to to have my finger
in the pose of what's going on out there
you know what I mean like and can be
overwhelming at times uh I try to see
like uh where culture is going
um and um and hopefully every now and
then we have a chance of influencing
culture a little bit too and it really
doesn't matter if it's gaming or a
burger or a soap you know like I think
if you have a powerful Insight a strong
positioning and you Embrace creativity
you'll be able to influence culture in
whatever category you are in in whatever
country you are in so to me like it's
about
it's about seeing where people's minds
are heading to you know like in trying
to find inflection points and trying to
predict things and trying to do things
that are going to surprise people where
where to pick I'm sorry please finish no
I think it's less about like doing a ton
of research and um uh and um because
research everyone has the same data you
know what I mean like I remember the
first time we've met uh and you were
telling me about how you used to look at
where drivers were looking at so that
you could put the signs of the wine
store that's right
um and you figured out that your thing
was not about the why necessary it was
more about consumer Behavior you know to
me it's about observation is
um and seeing where people are looking
at you know like uh pretty much like
what you did back in the day uh and I
think you continue to do so well
uh George Q from our office who's worked
with you in the past just said I miss
you fair uh uh Fernando what about big
companies where do they get this wrong
like you know you've been in enough at
this point I've always felt that the
reason you've over indexed it in this
industry is you are a little bit more
towards my world of Common Sense
consumer Behavior culture
you know what meetings do you walk out
of of like ah damn it this this could
have been better and the reason we're
doing this we're just so big or what
what is the you know for a lot of people
here who are entrepreneurs are getting a
lot of youngsters and you're trying to
get into marketing what's the what's the
cliche reason that companies are bad at
it
um I think I think that big companies or
any company for that matter can be bad
at it when um when everything is done
through full consensus and when people
are not empowered to take a direction
you know what I'm saying like uh like if
you were if if your idea of putting
signs around uh around like the Tenafly
in New Jersey uh who like had to be
agreed with your dad and 10 other
employees in the company they would be
like no that's why why when I see co-ceo
I jump out the window when you have two
c O's you have none I I I I I freak out
when I see dotted lines
you know you're like this you know what
I have in my company because we're a
global organization now we're you know
we're 2 000 people starting to be there
we have something called the Supreme
Court when there is in theory a dotted
line all I say is I don't want you to
spend more than one hour debating if you
two don't agree and you have your hands
in this jar you must come to me give me
your point of view I will make a Supreme
Court decision and we and the speed and
lack of politics that we've been able to
do with dotted I love you for saying
dotted lines are destroying corporations
I think I think the struggle is uh when
everything is driven by consensus when
people are not empowered uh when people
are risk averse so they they just want
to vote not not officially voting but
like they want to hear absolutely
everyone and and I don't mind hearing
everyone but someone at the end of the
day needs to make a decision uh and
you're probably not going to please
everyone when you try to please everyone
that's when I think it breaks that's
when like that's when you land on the
most common denominator which is usually
not the best uh way to go it's where
generic lives so um I think that's where
that's where we all struggle I would say
a lot of agencies watch this I always
love interacting with my contemporaries
when they watch this stuff so let's I
haven't asked a lot of questions from
that standpoint what is the biggest
mistake agencies are making your your
you know you don't have to talk about
your direct Partners I don't know who
that is but like in theory what you're
seeing like as you head into 2023 what
do you want more from from your agency
partners and what do you want less from
when it comes to being consumer-centric
yeah like I think look I mean what I
always want more from is close
collaboration and for them to to put
more ideas on the table then I can
execute you know I mean like potential
know my business know what my strategy
is know what we're trying to achieve in
literally like machine gun me uh with
ideas I would rather that we focus the
time on that part than um than on doing
bureaucratic stuff you know what I'm
saying
um and in ideas that will scare us you
know what I mean like that will push us
um I think that we're it is a but it's a
tricky thing it's what I'm saying is
like easier said and done like uh I
think that one of the biggest mistakes
that agencies can make is to try to
please the client you know then to the
client what you think the client will
like
because you if the client were an
amazing creative person uh the client
would be sitting on the agency side you
know what I mean like the fact that I
was lucky enough to be part of some
amazing creative projects doesn't mean
that I'm creative the ideas were not
coming from me you know it probably only
means that I know how to breathe well
that I have some criteria you know yeah
and I have a great relationship with the
with the with the creative Partners so
uh so that to me is the biggest mistake
distribution platforms whether it's
connected TV whether it's social whether
it's something traditional has you
personally most excited about
storytelling on
um I'm excited about Tick Tock to be
honest with you uh uh these days and I
know that you talk a lot about that
um and it's just a different way to do
storytelling you know what I mean like
uh and I think that we are all trying to
figure out for each franchise for each
brand for each company what is that way
you know like I also like I'm excited
about working with creators uh and
influencers you know like you are
talking about uh um
a fashion Nova I think like earlier like
you know like I think that there is
um there is a new way of doing doing
things that I think we're all kind of
still learning
um a way to like Leverage
power users of the brand to leverage
creators out there like the level of
Engagement that we are getting with
stuff that we do when we partner with
creators is infinite Times Higher of
course and how to do that without trying
to control the content which is the
stupid thing you hire created and then
you try to control the content tell my
clients you get to pick the Creator but
let her or him do their thing it's why
we keep them in the first place getting
them to do an ad destroys them and you
yeah but I think that we aren't you
joining the sense of like proving to
companies like the ROI on things like
that you know like they are everyone is
used to a certain way to do things uh
and disapprove try it and tested and
proven and easy to calculate payback Roi
like everything and I think that when um
when we try to do things in a different
way it's harder especially like the
first time you do it to prove the case
uh so it's finding that balance where we
can experiment
um and uh and learn and and show that
like we can evolve in the media
landscape and that we can like uh tell
stories in a different way than just
like long format films or uh or an ad or
like or an event you know what I mean I
love it Fernando always such a pleasure
my friend have a great holiday no you
too man awesome to see you guys thanks
for having me of course Fernando
next up super fired up to welcome Omar
Raja he's the leading voice behind ESPN
SportsCenter Instagram account and he
also makes appearances across platforms
across shows like hoop streams the
college football playoff show and Sports
Center thanks for joining us Omar no
worries thank you so much for having me
Omar I didn't I also see you in like a
Taco Bell did I just yeah yeah yeah you
did you did you did I was hyped yeah
that was really cool how are you I'm
doing good man how are you I'm quite
well
um why don't you spend one second
actually tell everybody how you came up
the game because I think it's gonna get
people hyped and then we'll go into it
cool it really started you know people
think about Instagram when I was 12 or
13 years old I wanted to be a YouTuber
so I was making like NBA 2K videos
Madden videos and honestly looking back
at it it never really popped off to the
level I wanted to but what it did was I
got so many reps and I learned so much
about community building and all that
stuff was when Instagram came around I
was like hey no one's doing video well
none of the media companies were posting
highlights or getting the funny moments
that were resonating more than like a
dunk right there was a lot of fan
moments of fans reacting in the
background to uh a play or a coach is
reacting and so I started an account
called House of highlights I made my own
goal to like build my own little you
know Sports Page and honestly it was
just a passion it wasn't supposed to be
this page that now has I think 35
million followers so
um I did that it blew up and uh Lebron
followed Cristiano Ronaldo followed so
you know and those two followed you just
lost your [ __ ] mind right you know
what the first one was Snoop Dogg I
remember he was the first celebrity to
follow and I remember calling my dad who
like isn't it doesn't know anything
about culture right and I was like do
you know who Snoop Dogg was he's like of
course I know who Snoop Dogg was so
that's when he made it I was like I've
made it I made it once I've got my dad's
uh not immigrant family life when your
parent can co-sign it says yeah yeah uh
look there this is really fun to have
you on this show because I you know we
know each other a little bit haven't had
the luxury of too much chop up time but
as we both have navigated
this last decade I think we I think this
will land with you there you know I
think you and I'm proud to say I think I
and there's others like us this is the
thing we really focus on it's pack it's
platform and culture right not only did
you understand the white space on
Instagram at the right time
you also had to really understand how
that platform was working so like what
were the design types what was the copy
the hashtags the every hack you know
what are you seeing today what's the
state no different than jamo who's in
the trenches talking about saves on Tick
Tock what's the Omar special on platform
and culture what are like things that
entrepreneurs unfortunate 100 should be
thinking about
oh I mean just all the different types
of content like you guys talk about
green screen videos I'm a huge fan of
that but also voice over video so I
believe in the storytelling of I'm gonna
take you at Steph Curry's workout and
show you what it's like this Saturday
where I'm going to USC versus UCLA so
many people are interested in that game
because it's a big you know two college
football teams and I'm gonna take you
behind the scenes I'm going to show you
what the players are working on I'm
going to tell you what they were young
about after the game ends whether it was
good or whether it was bad so I'm really
big on storytelling and just I have this
mic right here and I'm going to tell you
a bunch of stories that I think
um are relevant so I think that's
another format of stuff I also will say
like consistency people real quick I
apologize LinkedIn user1234 says damn
Gary you getting raided that siren is
wild no this is called New York City yes
now we [ __ ] do it yeah just want to
be sure if anyone was confused keep
going Omar no I think um consistency is
also just big being on every platform
one of the big learnings I had with
House of highlights was we were so big
on Instagram but then we made a tick
tock account and the account was
verified and had like 100 followers and
all the comments were what is House of
highlights and how did you guys get
verified you shouldn't have it right
like what what I'm like I thought we had
gen Z unlock so it was uh it was such a
you know humbling moment and you know
that's when we went hard on YouTube and
Instagram and Twitter and you know even
now for my personal accounts I'm trying
to be big on YouTube Tick Tock Instagram
all that stuff
what um how do you feel about
I don't know how in the trenches you are
on this these days but I have a feeling
you are
do you get excited when something you
post or your team post that you think is
going to crush fails like it's weird I'm
at this I love that yeah I'll tell you
why I love that one of my favorite
things to do on Tick Tock right now is I
Remix my video so if a video does bad
that I believe in
um one of the videos I actually had was
my story it was like how I started House
of highlights and how I ended up at ESPN
um and when I first made the video it
was 55 seconds it was just way too long
and it took me four tries to make that
video I made that video four times and I
think you got a thousand views a hundred
views every single time I posted it the
fifth time I posted that video it has
nine million views really yes it's
important for everyone to hear yes I
made a video
um why do UFC fighters put on Vaseline
um and you know before every fight
people you see that first time I did it
5 000 views I changed it I I I'm really
harsh on my video if I believe on it
I'll take out parts I'll redo the hook
19 million views on Tick Tock you I'm
not making any of this up it's no I know
I know you're not uh you saw the
headline I'm sure because you're in the
trenches like I am Mr Beast talks about
spending six figures on a thumbnail yes
yeah yeah it's just the little things it
matters like I don't you know I for one
you know
and like in love with the humility that
comes with it not hitting yes what I
like about you and I think we don't do
this enough Andrew for sure on our side
I don't work it enough because I'm
always on to the next on to the next but
there are absolutely things that I need
to do more working it and there's a lot
of people that run that model and for a
lot of people watching right now
going that second third fourth fifth
edit and giving it a shot especially
with the way the world works now where
the algorithms are just kind of like
taking it and like letting you win based
on the creative you know variable not
just how followers you have is a game
changer no I agree and I think another
thing also is like it can be the
littlest edit for like on Instagram what
we realize is we if a video did bad and
it didn't have text on screen hey you
just need to add that text on screen and
maybe add wait for it or watch the kid
in the back or watch this Fan's reaction
and that video might be going from
having 5 000 likes in 20 minutes to a
hundred thousand it really was the most
when you work it do you delete the
original from the grid I do I do if I
know I'm going to post it back if I know
if I'm gonna do edit two or edit three I
usually do delete it uh
huh how quickly I know it depends on the
platform I know on Tick Tock within twin
I mean I know on Instagram within 20
minutes
I'm in love with this Vaseline thing
yeah well you take it down as quickly as
30 40 minutes or will you give it like
three four hours or how do you like that
one was like I gave it a day because I
was like maybe it's popular what's the
fastest you'll take down
one hour one hour on tick tock
10 minutes on Instagram
10 minutes on Instagram you know that
you want to do something about
cam reddish is hot a little bit for the
next super hot he's into coffee you're
like I have this take on camera Edition
coffee yes post it on the gram and in 10
minutes because of the math you know
that it didn't hit but you know you're
gonna give it another at-bat you will
take it down yes we have it figured out
every on algorithms obviously change but
for the most part they don't change like
every other day so so we know that like
within two minutes this video should
have 500 likes if you know within five
minutes it should have a thousand like
we already know all the built-in stuff
we want a post in 20 minutes to have 50
000 likes whatever it is so a lot of
people feel the takedown is not good
like I haven't seen that and it seems
like you haven't seen that either like
it's taking it down and coming back a
couple hours later with something
different while you work on re-editing
that you have not seen a negative effect
I've never seen it I've done it since
2010 for a lot of people they don't
realize the takedown how quickly on a
takedown will you post something right
behind it like for for example on the
gram how often do you post
WE Post 10 to 12 times a day right so
every every two hours but yeah you're
probably not 24 7 so yeah the one tricky
thing is and imagine an NBA game or a
busy Saturday night UFC NFL college
football all these things are happening
you you can be posting on top of each
other
um and sometimes it feels like you know
real quick draw see this is live go
ahead oh yeah sometimes it feels like
you know you don't want to be posting
everything on top of it I'm a big
believer and if your content is good
enough it will eventually stand out so
it doesn't matter if you give it two
minutes of breathing room or two hours
are you saying boom I posted something
it's kind of hitting a little something
but it's a Saturday night with a lot of
sports I'm not scared to post another
thing because if that first thing is
really that good it will continue to do
well yes this is something I believe as
well that really scares the [ __ ] out of
people they want to let it breathe when
they don't realize you could have two
planes flying at the same time
absolutely Gary you're 100 correct well
listen we gotta run but I think people
gotta [ __ ] load of value in the last
four minutes and I really appreciate it
thank you so much Gary talk to you soon
bro
thanks Omar thanks Gary for joining us
a lot of great stuff everybody please
hang on to the show I got to go to
meetings but there's some fire fire
stuff coming up stuff that will actually
bring value the same way you just saw
bye take care love you all right next
let's bring up Zach Nadler he is the CEO
of Vayner speakers which is our speakers
Bureau and Zach I don't think I've had a
chance to tell you but I can't believe
that we're gonna bring will godara on he
was the leader of my favorite restaurant
well I can't believe we're gonna get a
chance to talk about this
um uh and and he's a best-selling author
so he's going to tell us all about the
story of how he took 11 Madison Park
from a two-star struggling Brasserie to
the one of the are the world's best 50
most popular restaurants in the world or
best restaurants in the world uh so
super fired up to hear a little bit more
about your National bestseller
unreasonable Hospitality thanks for
joining us will thank you so much
thanks Andrea uh as she mentioned will
ran 11 Madison Park the number one
restaurant in the world and recently
wrote a book about how he took this uh
simple idea uh and took his restaurant
to number one of the world
um with this simple idea of unusual
Hospitality so will welcome to marketing
for the now thanks bud it's good to be
here awesome so today's episode is all
about the consumer so let's Dive Right
In how do you define unreasonable
hospitality
you know when you look around and you
look at the most successful people
across Industries across disciplines
each one of them I've found is
unreasonable in pursuit of the product
they create
unreasonable Hospitality for me is just
making the choice to be just as
unreasonable just as Relentless but in
pursuit of how you serve that product
how you make the person you're serving
it to feel
yeah that's wild so give us give us an
example how how did you apply in
reasonable Hospitality uh to your time
at 11 Madison Park I mean I I stumbled
on to the idea one day it was a busier
than normal lunch service and I was in
the dining room helping out the servers
and I was clearing appetizers from a
table of four footies or on vacation to
New York and they're headed to the
airport to go back home after their
lunch and they were just talking about
all the amazing meals they had they were
talking about per se and Danielle and
Momofuku and now I love Madison Park but
then one person jumped in and said yeah
but we never had a hot dog from one of
those Street carts and it was like one
of those light bulb moments and I went
back into the kitchen dropped off the
plates ran outside of the hot dog cart
bought a hot dog ran back into the
kitchen now I came the hard part which
was convincing the chef to serve it
but eventually he agreed and we cut the
hot dog up into four perfect pieces
added a little swoosh of mustard and
ketchup and little canals of sauerkraut
and relish and
before their final Savory course which
was a honey lavender glazed Muscovy duck
that would dry Edge for two weeks
I brought over their dirty water dog
um
and I introduced it I said to make sure
you don't go home with any culinary
regrets on New York City hot dog and
Zach I mean they freaked out
you know I had served foie gras and
lobster and caviar you know over the
course of my career I'd never seen
anyone react the way that they did that
hot dog and it really changed the way I
looked at the restaurant business from
that point forward
at that point we were already one of the
top 50 restaurants in the world but we'd
gotten there by being so focused on
Excellence right on all the little
details that I hadn't yet realized
something really important
that our reason for being in restaurants
and honestly any customer service
business is to make people feel seen to
give them a sense of belonging to make
them feel welcome
and so I started breaking down like what
are the things that led to that gesture
and what could I do to start making sure
it was happening all the time
um first thing it just required being
present which is so overused these days
but for me being present is just caring
so much about the person you're with
that you stop caring about all the other
things you need to do
and it's something that a lot of people
struggle with anyone out there that
thinks they're good at multitasking I
think you're wrong I don't think it's
possible to be good at it it just means
you're doing two things
moderately well instead of one thing
really well
um if I had been present I never would
have heard the line about the hot dog
two it required the the belief that we
should take what we do seriously without
taking ourselves too seriously
I think in customer service so many
people like spend so much time building
these perfect Brands and then let these
self-impose standards get in the way of
them giving their guests the things that
will actually make them happy
a hot dog in a four-star restaurant is
sacrilegious until you look at the way
that it made them feel
and then third it just required the
acknowledgment that if what you're
trying to do is give people a sense of
belonging one size fits one
and so man I the hot dog was like the
true north and in those three things we
had a road map and I started talking
about it constantly with the team and we
got started right away each night coming
up with cool little one-off gestures for
the guests but what I learned is that if
you really believe in an idea you need
to also give your team the resources to
execute it consistently
um and so we added a position to our
team someone whose only responsibility
was to help everyone and the team bring
their ideas to life we called it the
Dreamweaver because I'm a little bit
obsessed with the song by Gary Wright
and with that I've given my team
permission to do cool [ __ ] for our team
or for our guests and then the resources
to help them do it
um
a guest warned us in advance that his
dad was more of a Budweiser steak and
potatoes guy than champagne and caviar
so the dreamweavers turned our fancy
champagne cart into a Budweiser cart
with every available type of bottled Bud
from all the bodegas in the neighborhood
um a couple came in to console
themselves after their Beach vacation
flight was canceled so the dreamweavers
turned our private dining room into
their very own private beach we put a
bunch of sand on the ground a kiddie
pool filled with water that they get
their feet into
um and this is what was so cool about it
when we talk about how to be
consumer-centric
I mean I believe that this is the
absolute key to that and it was a
win-win-win a we are more profitable
than ever before yet this requires
investment
got the ROI on that investment was
incredible I mean you couldn't get into
the restaurant after enough of these
stories started spreading into the world
um but also our team was just happier
than ever before first because they had
creative agency they weren't just
serving plates of food that someone else
had created they were coming up with
their own ideas and those ideas were
impacting the experience we turned
product we turned sales people into
product designers and there's no one on
Earth that won't give more of themselves
to make something successful and they
had then when they have a hand in
creating it
but we were also
just all happier because we're making
other people really happy
you know one of the things that people
are struggling with right now is
staffing issues and it's based on birth
and depletion and
I mean listen I don't think there's
anything more energizing than seeing the
look of complete Joy on someone's face
than you when they receive a gift you're
responsible for giving them
and so work is depleting sometimes but
if you can make the work energizing as
well
that's an amazing key to success wow I
and I also will say having eaten at 11
Madison Park if you serve me a hob like
it probably would have been a different
uh outcome but I I the meal was
incredible nonetheless well no the
gestures should own they're only good if
they only make sense to the person
receiving them absolutely well and so
explain this because obviously this
isn't
um a restaurant you know um session this
is this has leaders from all sorts of
different Industries so how can someone
else in whatever industry they're in you
know outside of hospitality actually
apply these same ideas to their business
yeah this is not just for fancy
restaurants
um and it honestly doesn't even require
a huge budget remember the Hot Dog costs
two dollars I mean listen like for most
of America's history we were a
manufacturing economy now we're a
service economy that means that most of
the people watching this do the same
thing for a living that I do we're all
in the business of serving other people
um and if you start to look closely
enough and you do some simple pattern
recognition these kind of opportunities
will emerge like take real estate agents
every single time I've bought a new
apartment in the city at best at best
the agents left me a bottle of the
sparkling wine in the fridge as my thank
you slash congratulations gift now this
is someone with whom I've spent weeks if
not months looking together for my new
home if they've been paying attention
they should know every intimate detail
about my life imagine if instead the
first time my wife and I walked into the
place we ended up falling in love with
they overheard her talking about the
Nook she could imagine herself doing
yoga and imagine if when we moved in
instead of that obligatory bottle of
bubbles there was a brand new yoga mat
along with a candle and a note that said
welcome to your new home
a that would be pretty cool but B
compared to the average commission it's
an insignificant investment in what will
inevitably become a lifelong
relationship
I think every business if you look
closely enough you find these
opportunities and and I think you need
to because
listen making good products I don't
think it's enough anymore
um serving them efficiently is not
enough anymore I I really do believe
it's now how we make people feel those
that we work with and those that we
serve that matters the most of all I I
believe that we're on the precipice of
becoming a Hospitality economy wow well
I think you're onto something because
obviously there's almost an expectation
now right what you are getting right is
this is the Baseline expectation I
should be getting this I deserve this so
it's how do you separate from the
competition using tools like this to
really make yourself uh and your
business separate yourselves from the
competition
um so I appreciate this will thank you
so much for joining us um for everyone
out there if you enjoyed this I will
have to give a Shameless plug Will's
book is available now on reasonable
Hospitality so don't be shy about going
to Amazon or your local bookstore and
picking up a copy thanks will thanks bud
it's going to make it in my uh holiday
list that's for sure
thanks so much Zach that was really
great we're getting lots of good
comments in the in the chat here about
how if you truly care for others your
business is going to grow and so I think
you know it's like these things are
really important to remind ourselves
something super simple but you know we
we easily forget some of the things that
just are about caring that's what we do
here right take things from being a
transaction to a relationship that's
right absolutely thanks so much for
joining us Zach thanks Adrian
all right we're gonna welcome up my mud
Johnson my mom are you here
creative director first time on
marketing for the now it's about time
it's so exciting no pressure Andrea
that's right that's right and very fired
up to have tressy Lieberman join us she
is one of the super powers at Chipotle
um we've been uh you know watching her
work very very closely we're excited to
talk to her because she's a big Maven
she's super connected to culture and
she's responsible for a lot of things um
at Chipotle that are all about Community
engagement so we're really looking
forward to hearing more about some of
the tricks of the trade thanks for
joining us Chelsea thanks for having me
hi everybody absolutely thank you so
much for joining us trusty um like you
heard Andrea say
um you know we bow down to Chipotle we
obviously think you all are doing a
fantastic job
um I think one of the best ways to start
this conversation is just a quick shout
out to the amazing work you're doing
Chipotle is the most followed food brand
on Tick Tock which is insane so a little
hair toss
for Chipotle um a big reason for that is
that you guys have always been ahead of
the game in understanding platforms and
exploding culture right which is a big
topic that we're talking about today so
I think it would help if maybe you can
start by just sharing you know what tell
us a little bit about why this almost
Obsession that you guys have with
cracking culture has been such a big
part of exploding the Chipotle brand
over the past few years
great yeah well first off thank you and
thanks to the team at Chipotle because
they're the amazing people that are
making this happen uh you know I think
one it just starts with our fans so our
entire strategy is to supercharge the
super fans and chipotle is really
fortunate that we are loved and you know
when people talk about Chipotle they are
passionate about it and to ask people
their order I know a Chipotle fan
because they don't say I like a chicken
bowl they tell you every single
ingredient that they like on that
chicken bowl and we have really leaned
into that I've been laser focused on
those unique Chipotle insights that we
can tap into I think when you look at a
unique Chipotle insight and you tie That
Into You know what is a brand about but
what do the consumers care about and
then you connect culture into it that's
where you just see the magic happen
that's where we see things take off you
know we did a water cup candle a few
months ago and that was just a simple
Insight that people like to you know
have that wink about getting lemonade
out or getting lemonade when they're
thinking they're getting water so they
see take out lemonade so we're like you
know what we could ignore that or we
could have fun with it so we made a
water cup candle that happens to smell
like lemonade and it blew up and I think
that's a really good example of you know
what's the brand about what is that wing
with our customers and how do we tap
that into culture something people can
touch and feel and experience around the
brand and that takes courage right
that's one of those things where a lot
of Brands would be afraid of that of
saying like oh we don't want people to
think that that's something that we're
okay with and you realize you guys are
like no because real people are telling
us this let's lean into it and you only
know that by listening on those
platforms yeah I mean it's it's that
moment where someone says Chipotle gets
me oh I see that you know they see me
we're always asking why would I care and
why would I share we asked that for
every single idea something I learned
from a Facebook partner I mean really
long time ago I think when Facebook
first you know expanded Beyond college
students and I've been using that ever
since to think about like why would
somebody want to talk about this and the
simplest ideas can really create create
a huge spark no that's a that's a great
Point why would I care and why would I
share I'm going to burn that one in my
brain forehead tattoo of that one I
think another part of that that you just
mentioned
um that's really important to this is
understanding platforms and how to act
on them right like you're not acting
like a brand you're acting like a real
person and which is why I think people
feel so close to the Chipotle brand so I
think the other part of this right we
talked about culture
um let's talk about platforms for just a
second because I think Chipotle again
has always been ahead of the game when
it comes to being a first mover on Tick
Tock and now you guys are like killing
it on be real so would love for you to
just tell us a little bit about how you
guys stay at the Forefront of what's
happening with the platforms sure well
the mindset across our organization
really not just a social team is culture
hunting and the team is obsessed with
understanding you know where are
consumers where are they talking about
Chipotle and where might we provide
value if we show up there and we're big
fans of not debating it endlessly but
actually just jumping in and
experimenting and I think the best way
that you can learn is to do
um you can sit in the sidelines and and
observe but you know we as an early
leader on Tick Tock in 2019 we have
several years behind us to know what
works what doesn't work and to be ready
when things change and evolve and just
keep experimenting so that is ingrained
in the way that we operate as a business
and we really try to build that muscle
where we can move fast we can break
things and have fun doing it not take
ourselves too seriously you know we
always say that we take our food
seriously but not ourselves and I think
that's really important when it comes to
the work and making it more human and
more relatable to your point absolutely
and I think that's so important
especially when it comes to those newer
platforms again Tick Tock back in 2019
when you guys were first doing it and
now be real as it is a newer platform
like you have to take those risks or
you're never going to see those big
rewards like you guys are seeing into
your point because you've had so many at
bats you have more opportunities to find
success which I I think again a lot of
Brands could be scared of that but you
all have really really embraced it
absolutely I think you have to in social
media like you you just need to jump in
absolutely
um you know and I think one of the great
examples from the past few weeks where
you guys have like totally exploded that
cross-section of platforms and culture
as with corn kid
um about a month ago if you are on this
uh marketing for the now broadcast and
you have not seen corn cat corn kid
please just Google it right now it will
make your day the song will get stuck in
your head
um but I think Chipotle again this is a
great example of how because you all
have such a deep understanding of what's
happening in culture you're able to
identify this signal really early on
before any other brand was able to jump
onto it and then do you know an
activation on Tick Tock within a few
hours so I'd love for you to take this
crew through how that exactly happened
how it started how your team reacted how
quickly you got that out into the
marketplace and then what were some of
the results that you saw from it
yeah I mean I think it's an example of
Chipotle you know operating at our best
pulling our strategy together and moving
really quickly
um in that example the team saw that
there was the corn kid Tara he's
adorable saw this trend taking off on
Tick Tock with his video and for us
we're like okay does this make sense for
our brand is could this be uniquely
Chipotle like we don't want to just jump
on trends for the sake of being in a
trend we need to feel relatable and of
course we are very focused on our real
ingredients that's quarter who Chipotle
is and we have corn as an ingredient so
uh 15 right yeah the team's like okay
what's the right execution and I think
that's the magic of it right the content
was really good because we showed him
going through the line and passing on
every ingredient aside from corn and
then you get the big reveal at the end
when he says it's corn corn I mean it's
just such a cool example because Neve
toledano who led that project like she
saw it happening found his agent like
you know found the person who could
connect us to him yeah team on the
ground in New York who's able to get him
into a restaurant shoot the content
publish the content all happened within
24 hours so you know if that's something
you can't just do overnight that took a
lot of experimentation building the
capability to move real time to have the
partnership with legal to you know have
the team on the ground in different
places where we can capture content to
you know have a creative idea and be
able to get the approval internally to
be able to make things happen and I
think it's a great example right because
it's had well over 100 million views and
just the comments are insane just so
much passion for the brand and I mean
that's the best advertising you can
possibly do there's no money behind it
it's just a great idea that popped off
you know that magic doesn't happen every
time but it just continues to show the
power of what can happen when you
execute really well on an idea that is
relevant for your brand absolutely and
again execute really well understanding
platform forms tying it to what's
happening in culture it was such a
simple idea but it had so much power and
I think that's a true Testament to what
you guys are building both as a brand
with what you're doing you're doing but
also the people in the systems that
you've put in place across your
organization and with your advertising
and agency partners to be able to make
that happen within just a matter of a
few hours yeah and it's a lot of fun
there's nothing better than getting to
create content like that and just see
that immediate response from our fans
amazing who can't who can't love it
uh no thank you so much trusty for
joining us today seriously um we are in
awe of what you guys are doing at
Chipotle and we're going to keep
watching for all the amazing stuff to
come Andrea we'll toss it back over to
you
thank you Tracy and thank you maima that
was delicious I'm getting hungry
delicious in every way
thanks Mama we'll see you soon all right
next up we are going to welcome our
Jason Loomis who heads up all things
media at vaynerx's Sasha group hey how's
it going Jason it's going great it's a
pleasure to be here and uh you know
excited excited to to talk about what
we're going to talk about but also a
little nervous after following all of
what I know right what a lineup but
we're gonna we're gonna bring it home
today we've got the CEO of hello product
what a way to conclude this show I'm
really excited about this one raika Rao
was has been at Colgate for over 20
years is that right Reika and then you
just joined as the CEO of hello product
at the beginning in January of 2020 and
I just love your brand love the fact
that you guys have your own culture and
then how you interact with the world
we're really really fired up to have
this conversation today so thanks to you
both for joining us awesome thank you
Reika I'm really pumped about this just
to kind of build on what was just said
there um it was really exciting I think
that was a perfect tee up uh when we're
talking about platforms and culture and
being consumer-centric
um you know one of the first things
that's really struck me about hello ever
since you know we started working
together even before that that you know
everything from like the packaging the
product design the brand name itself
hello like it's so clearly and obviously
consumer-centric and was designed and
built with the consumer first
um and you know I I'm curious your
opinion you know how do you think
Hello's early consumer-centric Focus
allowed it to scale as quickly as it did
you know to what degree excuse me my
throat's cracking a little bit do that
play into to the Brand's success
yeah absolutely I think that people
human centricity is the core of the
brand and honestly was the magic uh that
is behind the brand so when Craig and
the founding team developed it I think
it was that human-centric touch that
they they they captured and in fact uh
totally agree whether it's the brand
name itself of hello whether it is the
tone with which the brand speaks and
shows up differently it really
fundamentally added a direct human touch
to the Oral Care category whether it's
about how it speaks to the benefits of
the category uh the counter-worthy
design and packaging and ultimately
these beautiful delightful thoughtful
touches uh that the brand really you
know wants to make the world the
friendlier happier place and does it in
super beautiful ways
um to me one of the the the best
examples of this is we have our unicorn
Sparkle toothpaste not sure how many of
you know but what you can do is actually
open up our carton here and literally
there's a an area to color for kids but
again you wouldn't know it it's a
surprise point it's a delight point and
it's all about that human-centric touch
that is so core to the brand and
certainly we we don't even speak about
our our consumers as consumers they are
our brushers and our swishers and we we
love them dearly
well I will say when I got the the
welcome pack when we first started
working together you all sent me
um a variety of the different toothpaste
and everything and gave some to my
nephews uh and they immediately turned
their family into a hello Crusher family
they started demanding that their
parents buy them hello and hello only so
it definitely works on that front
um so next I love that and it makes so
much sense and you know I think
obviously that approach and everything
you did got the attention of Colgate uh
where you've been
um for for a long time and you know one
of the things that that was interesting
to me is I think sometimes when Brands
smaller Brands get bought up by these
larger holding companies they can lose
some of that identity you know and I
think sometimes you know the larger
structure starts to infuse like hey this
is how we do things this is what you
need to do and everything gets focused
on the p l and focused on the sales
numbers and you lose that core but I
really think you know hello and Colgate
both have done an incredible job of
maintaining that and I wonder if you can
talk a little bit about that of like how
have you been able to maintain your core
identity
um as hello kind of moves into the
Colgate world
yeah absolutely first and foremost I
think Colgate itself is a very
human-centric people-centric brand that
obviously uh has been around for for 200
plus years to really understand that
consumer so I think first that that is
built on the foundation of what congole
believes into
um that being said I think there's just
a powerful partnership that exists uh
and really a belief that that hello the
brand uh is about building that magic
building that you know touch with the
consumer and our brushers and swishers
and it's about amplifying it now so it's
really about scaling it and building it
and amplifying it but at the core of it
making sure we retain that you know
really delightful brand experience which
is ultimately what we're delivering so I
think that's that's super important and
it's it's happening yeah and how about
how are you able to you know I've seen
you guys do this a little bit too of how
are you able to take advantage of some
of the resources and so the Scott the
size and scale of Colgate but not get
bogged down by some of the process that
comes along with all the decision makers
and just the size of the company overall
how have you been able to manage that
yeah absolutely I think what we try to
do is really tap in to those resources
into the tools into the subject matter
expertise that exists that really helps
amplify the brand
um so you know we probably have started
adding a touch of structure to this
people's centricity whether it's
leveraging a host of great agile
consumer-centric research tools
um and things of that sort you know
really building on our consumer
experience teams to really kind of
connect with Community the consumer and
our brushers and swishers uh in some
nice great new ways so really leveraging
those teams to maintain and amplify that
human touch is really where we're trying
to find those those places to connect
love that
talk a little bit about your Evolution
with Tick Tock as well because you know
speaking of being agile uh you know I
know in 2020 around that time uh yo
we're much more TV Centric in terms of
your media investment and that has
changed dramatically from from immediate
perspective but also just from an
organic effort perspective and how much
content you create and you guys have
really developed you know Best in Class
Tick-Tock presence and Tick Tock content
I'd love to hear your perspective of you
know how you were able to make that
shift happen and what you think that's
done for the brand
yeah absolutely I think back to being
actually really laser focused on our
brushers and swishers
um it became abundantly clear that
they're on Tick Tock uh and they're on
it a lot uh and of course social overall
so you know we quickly identified that
you know at a full platform basis social
digital is going to be where you know we
need to focus
second on Tick Tock we really thought it
was a great place for the brand to show
up to engage to entertain to really just
take that brand messaging and
amplification in ways that really not
not money had been doing so really
really excited we launched our own
organic Tick Tock in April and quickly
scaled to 168 000 followers 1 million
likes in a matter of uh of seven months
so incredible work by you know powerful
teams uh across across really hello NR
agency partners that I couldn't be more
thankful to but really that that really
what what it was about was connecting
with people
um and really building that community of
positivity and certainly that's
something we take a lot of pride in uh
which is you know really understanding
the positive sentiment of the brand
across all our social platforms and and
we're really you know we we take those
relationships uh very seriously and we
don't take them for granted so
cultivating that trust cultivating that
Community making sure we listen and
engage
um is really the the priority across all
our platforms yeah I love that and I
also love you know it struck me um a
little bit Gary talks about this a lot
of this concept if it's never too late
you know and and I think sometimes
people like oh I missed the boat on this
or it's too late for me to really invest
from just organic maybe I'll just get on
with paid and I think that that you all
did a great job of it's it's not too
late now is the time and you invest and
you see the results right it's paying
dividends so that's really tremendous I
know we're running up on time here I've
got one more question for you
um and that is really you know a lot of
times especially in in cpg world you
know you talk about these angle biter
Brands and you know you all are beyond
that point now hello is much much
further along than that but with that
that kind of upward momentum the fast
growth you've experienced and everything
you're doing from a consumer-centric
standpoint what do you think you've
brought to Colgate like what do you
think you hello is teaching Colgate and
the rest of the brands within the
portfolio
yeah absolutely I think that again
collaboration partnership has been great
uh so first I think it's probably about
the agility with which hello can move uh
and how we're trying to to push so I
think that that learning has been great
and then there's other things we do
things a little differently at hello
related to process
um maybe things like even how we conduct
our interviews are a little different uh
well of course we we we bring folks in
to understand their capabilities and
skills but we actually do some things
differently to understand who they are
as people and how they'll they'll really
connect with with us as a company and I
think that approach sometimes now we're
starting to see Triple n in a lot of
different ways within within Colgate as
well so it's really about you know
taking taking you know some nice
learnings on what hello does differently
and how that may actually help the rest
of the organization
that's awesome Reagan thank you so much
this was awesome I really enjoyed it
absolutely it's absolutely it was so
good I love the brushers and the
swishers
taking it in and love that last that
last question it's it's super
interesting just to see how one of the
smaller Brands can be so mighty within a
broader organization all the learnings I
think tons of tons of relevance there so
thank thanks to you both for for the
conversation
fabulous
thank you Jason and thanks to all of you
for joining us today we're going to have
another episode coming up in December on
December 13th it's going to be from 12
noon to 1 pm eastern time so we hope
that you'll come back right here for
that uh we're going to be doing uh an
episode that's all about a year in
review uh with vaynermedia so it feels
like a good time to reflect please join
us you can sign up uh by going to mftn
that's for marketing for the now so
mftn.vaynerx.com and we hope you are
will do well between now and then we'll
see you soon thanks for coming